[Música]
siguen las protestas indígenas en
ecuador 16 policías que habían sido
retenidos ya fueron liberados aunque dos
siguen en poder de las comunidades por
su parte la ong fundamedios han
reportado 72 agresiones contra la prensa
el presidente de eeuu yo bailé pidió al
congreso que apruebe una suspensión de
tres meses de los impuestos a la
gasolina la medida busca combatir la
subida de los precios y brindar alivio
temporal a las familias pues explicamos
desde washington
al menos 23 personas han muerto a causa
de las intensas lluvias en guatemala el
gobierno declaró la calamidad pública en
8 de las 22 provincias del país pero la
medida tendrá que ser ratificada por el
congreso tenemos reporte de nuestros
corresponsables
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muños empezamos en ecuador
en el décimo día de protestas indígenas
la policía informó que 18 agentes fueron
retenidos tras un ataque contra una
estación ubicada en la ciudad de puyo en
la región de la amazonía 16 de ellos ya
fueron liberados y están en buen estado
de salud según el ministerio del
interior por su parte la ong fundamedios
registró por lo menos 72 agresiones
contra la prensa por parte de los
manifestantes y también de agentes del
estado desde quitó nuestro corresponsal
gustavo ortega nos explicó qué ha
sucedido con los intentos de diálogo
entre las partes
y específicamente ante la solicitud de
un diálogo la presentación de propuestas
por parte de la conae y la
intermediación de aproximadamente 300
organizaciones civiles el diálogo se ha
estancado específicamente la única si se
ha dicho que luego de haber asistido a
cuatro diálogos previos él considera que
esta situación no amerita una
intervención una mediación por parte de
organizaciones civiles de ha dicho o más
bien que desea una mediación ha
condicionado al ejecutivo en nacional de
levantar la militarización de toda esta
zona levantar también el estado de
excepción y sobre todo toda esta zona
que bordea la casa de la cultura y el
parque del arbolito sea desmilitarizada
por lo tanto también leonidas iza hizo
un llamado a distintas organizaciones
sociales a que luego de realizar una
asamblea popular pudieran responder así
al presidente de la república pero hasta
este momento el diálogo se ha frenado y
no sé avisar una pronta solución en los
próximos días
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
pidió al congreso que apruebe una
suspensión de tres meses de los
impuestos a la gasolina en medio de un
alza récord en los precios
previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez quien nos contó qué
posibilidades hay de que esta medida
pase en el legislativo
en este momento el galón de gasolina que
está pagando el estadounidense en
promedio es de cinco dólares por galón
el presidente yo bailé dijo que con la
suspensión de los impuestos federales de
18 centavos a la gasolina regular 24
centavos a la gasolina diésel que
también con la suspensión de los
impuestos estatales a la gasolina y
aumentando la capacidad de refinación de
las empresas petroleras en este país se
lograría ahorrar entonces hasta 1 dólar
por galón sin embargo pues va a ser
bastante difícil que estas medidas sean
aprobadas por el congreso esto porque
hasta los propios demócratas están en
contra de esta medida y los republicanos
dicen que simplemente sería un golpe a
la industria energética además muchos
críticos decir que esta reducción que de
hecho los impuestos a la gasolina en
eeuu solamente representan el 5 por
ciento del precio total es una política
entonces que muchos dicen también es
estratégica de cara a que la suspensión
iría hasta finales de septiembre días
antes de las elecciones legislativas el
gobierno de guatemala declaró la
calamidad pública en 8 de las 22
provincias por los problemas que han
ocasionado las intensas lluvias en el
sureste del país este temporal ya ha
dejado por lo menos 23 personas muertas
y más de 1,3 millones están afectadas
desde la ciudad de antigua nuestro
corresponsal andrés suárez no se
ampliaba previamente los detalles
la temporada de lluvias de centroamérica
y el sur de méxico está agravando la
seguridad de millones de personas en la
región hoy en el congreso de guatemala
necesito de emergencia a lincecum y de
la conred las dos instituciones que en
este país centroamericano trabajan por
el monitoreo de los eventos climáticos
así como por la reducción de desastres y
se llegó a la conclusión que la
temporada invernal de mayo a noviembre
2022 será mucho peor que la de años
anteriores esto por cuenta el fenómeno
de la niña así como por la previsión de
51 eventos climáticos entre los que se
destacan más de 20 tormentas tropicales
y varios huracanes que afectarán tanto
la costa este como oeste de este país
el presidente alejandro giammatei además
analizó las cifras mientras en 2021
murieron 31 personas por cuenta de las
lluvias en lo corrido del 2022 llama más
de una veintena de muertos varios
desaparecidos un millón 300 mil personas
afectadas y por esto tomó la decisión de
decretar el estado de calamidad pública
en 8 departamentos entre los que se
cuenta el lugar dónde estamos aquí
antigua guatemala como la ciudad capital
ciudad de guatemala una medida que
durará 30 días donde se limitará el
movimiento de personas se ordenará
además la evacuación de más de 140
municipios considerados de alto riesgo
donde hay probabilidad de deslaves de
inundaciones que pudiesen llegar a
causar una tragedia humana de grandes
proporciones
el 45 por ciento de los menores de edad
que participaron en un estudio de la
organización save the children afirmaron
que no quería migrar ellos viven en
nuestros países centroamericanos del
triángulo norte el salvador guatemala y
honduras
en lo que va del año 2022 cada hora 15
jóvenes centroamericanos o de mexico
migraron hacia el norte del continente
sin ser acompañados por un adulto huyen
de la violencia los impactos del cambio
climático y para reunirse con sus
familiares que ya están en eeuu pero
según la organización save the children
no todos los niños del triángulo norte
de centroamérica quieren abandonar sus
países que los jóvenes muchas veces
deciden por sí mismo si van o no van y
la razón principal es para buscar la
oportunidades económicas en el país de
destino
la ong entrevistó a 122 jóvenes de 7 a
19 años para el estudio llamado debería
quedarme o debería irme y concluyó que
el 43 por ciento quería quedarse en su
país o aún no tenía intención de emigrar
el 24 por ciento si tenía intención de
emigrar el 17 por ciento no sabía con
seguridad si seguiría mientras que un 16
por ciento no respondió
6 de junio una caravana de miles de
inmigrantes especialmente
centroamericanos salió desde honduras un
viaje peligroso y lleno de obstáculos
[Música]
para poder permitir
para poder avanzar en volver
estaba colapsado
entonces bueno vamos a seguir en la
marcha para ver por qué nos dieron que
si llegamos a otros pueblos podríamos
tener la oportunidad de obtener el
documento con el informe las niñas
quieren migrar pero son las que más
dificultades encuentran para irse
primero por el riesgo que corren en el
camino y segundo por los roles de género
ya que se sienten claves dentro de la
familia de enero a abril de este año 47
mil jóvenes no acompañados intentando
llegar a méxico y eeuu fueron
interceptados por la policía y siguen
siendo días difíciles para cuba por la
falta de energía la empresa estatal que
regula el tema reconoció que habrá
nuevos apagones luz se va casi a diario
en algunos sectores de la isla el
gobierno sostiene que los cortes en el
suministro son por roturas en la planta
por mantenimientos y por el déficit de
combustible
crisis energética en cuba y con ella
continúan los apagones los cubanos
acostumbrados a este tipo de situaciones
esperan pacientes fuera de sus casas
para aplacar el calor pero son otros
tiempos y no temen en mostrar su
descontento
[Música]
lo que sea una fácil
bastante bastante intolerante
el presidente cubano miguel díaz canel
recorrió esta semana todas las centrales
termoeléctricas la mayoría con
tecnología obsoleta la unión eléctrica
de cuba ha notificado más de 300
afectaciones en las 13 centrales del
país sus trabajadores extienden a 12
horas su jornada laboral para atenuar la
situación estamos luchando para eliminar
un poco lo apagó el mandatario cubano
dijo que por el momento no habrá mejora
una inversión en termoeléctricas es
sumamente costosa para el país y por
otra parte una inversión que demora años
o sea de inmediato no se logra montar un
arte moderno con un país amigo tiene
suscrito un acuerdo una negociación
mediante la cual se establecerían tres
nuevos bloques en el país eso es
pensando en el crecimiento que va a
tener el país en el futuro expertos
temen que la situación se escale y lleva
a los cubanos otra vez a la calle como
la tormenta perfecta por qué
o sea ya ha pasado no se ha pasó la
pandemia
cuesta una crisis económica profunda ya
hubo protestas significativas del año
pasado se ha mantenido ese sentimiento
de descontento social ahora vuelven los
apagones llega el verano
es como todo al mismo tiempo las
sanciones contra rusia uno de los
principales aliados de la habana por su
invasión a ucrania el aumento de los
precios de los alimentos y del petróleo
agudiza la crisis en el país caribeño
impactaba principalmente por el embargo
económico estadounidense
así que es informativa en brands 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]